los angeles new district attorney
george gascon has announced that
enforcing the law is racist
to fight systemic racism george gascon
is dropping prosecutions
and cutting inmates sentences office
will begin
an unprecedented effort to reevaluate
and resentence thousands of cases
racism on the death penalty in our
country are
in a strictly intertwined the reality is
the
death penalty does not make us safer it
is
racist it's morally untenable
it's irreversible and expensive
and beginning today is off the table in
l.a county
to demonstrate his commitment to quote
anti-racism gascorn made a big show of
cutting ties with the california
district attorneys association
according to gascon the group is just
too white it doesn't have
enough people of color but according to
the head of the california district
attorney's association
vern pierson gascon hasn't been a member
for a terribly
long time uh vern pearson joins
us now uh van is this a devastating blow
for your
organization to have uh mr gascorn
abandoning it
well no it's not and the the reason is
he's no more able to resign from our
association than
that i'm able to resign from the
starting lineup of the giants
he is not a member of the association
nor has he been a member of the
association since october
of 2019 when he quit his job as district
attorney of san francisco
uh it's important to note the the
hypocrisy here i mean he's
he is raising this issue and
uh in in the context of a publicity
stunt
really he a few weeks ago
we filed an amicus brief in l.a county
in support of a lawsuit that alleged
that he was violating the law he the
chief prosecutor in l.a county
was alleged to be violating the law last
week the judge sided with us
in and the deputy da's in la in that
lawsuit
and then here a week later he supposedly
uh
resigns from our very diverse
association
in protest when he hasn't been a member
for years
now just just to be clear on that then
why isn't he
a laughingstock in california as you say
it's an obvious
stunt you know it's like you resigning
from the giants it's like me
resigning from the un security council
why isn't
why isn't everybody just making him a
completely ridiculous figure
in californian public life well i think
that's
that's happening very quickly it's
important let's take a
quick step back uh he was appointed
district attorney in san francisco in
2011.
by 2019 when he resigned property crimes
were up by 50 percent
violent crimes were up significantly he
was so unpopular
when he resigned from san francisco it
was impossible for him to be re-elected
in fact when he moved to la and then ran
for district attorney backed by
a handful of billionaires that including
george soros that funded his campaign
the mayor the african-american mayor of
san francisco
london breed supported his opponent
so now what we're seeing is that it took
eight
seven eight years for the people of san
francisco to really turn on mr gascon
and in just a very short period of time
in la the people are turning on him and
there's a recall effort that's already
uh uh forming uh to call recall him
yeah let's let's hope that works i don't
think there were even in california i
don't think there were enough counties
for a failure like this guy to keep
moving to thank you very much uh for
that vern
and uh great to have the word from you
he's resigning for it's like a
variation of the old groucho marx line
not caring to belong
to a group that would have him as a
member in this case he isn't a member
but he's resigning on principle foreign
anyway
great stuff van